Bienvenue à toutes et tous, ravie de vous
retrouver ici ! La vidéo du jour est sponsorisée
par Nextory, une application de lecture, la
seule qui propose tous les formats : livres
audio, BD, presse, podcast, ebook. La plupart
du temps sur Passé sauvage on vous présente
des bouquins, mais j’ai bien conscience
que la lecture papier n’est pas forcément
accessible pour tout le monde et n’est surtout
pas la seule manière de profiter d’un livre.
Sur Nextory vous avez de tout, je vous partage
là ma bibliothèque : je l’organise par
genre, il y a de la fiction, ici du réel
(là dedans je regroupe souvent les autobiographies),
et puis une section archéo mais pas que,
c’est ici que je range des ouvrages qui
me serviront pour la chaîne justement. Je
vous mets toute cette sélection dans la barre
de description, vous pourrez découvrir ce
contenu sur l’application Nextory. Par exemple,
écouter Tristes Tropiques de Lévi-Strauss
ou bien ce livre Pierre Clastres qui doit
être passionnant, un entretien avec Michelle
Perrot ou encore de la poésie : les Ronces
de Cécile Coulon est une merveille
Grâce à ce lien qui s’affiche ici vous
avez accès à une période d’essai de 45
jours offerts (au lieu de 14 habituellement)
sur l’abonnement standard. Vous avez 15h
d’écoute par mois sur tous les supports
(ebooks, BD, presse, podcast et bien-sûr
livre audio.) Je vous laisse découvrir les
deux autres forfaits directement sur l'application
Nextory. J’espère que ça vous plaira,
en tout cas vous avez une belle promo pour
essayer.
Il y a de nombreuses théories sur les voyages
précolombiens à destination de l’Amérique.
Il s’agit souvent d’hypothèses très
difficiles à prouver voire carrément fantaisistes.
On en a déjà évoqué quelques-unes dans
les vidéos de la chaîne comme la supposée
traversée de l’Atlantique depuis l’Afrique
de l’Ouest au XIVe siècle, ou bien celle
des Egyptiens qui seraient allés apprendre
aux Mayas à construire des pyramides. Côté
chinois, on imagine parfois que l’amiral
Zheng He se serait lui aussi aventuré jusqu’aux
Caraïbes au début du XVe siècle. Malheureusement
pour les amateurs de ces théories, il n’en
existe à l’heure actuelle aucune preuve
archéologique.
Pourtant, il ne faut pas jeter le bébé avec
l’eau du bain et affirmer comme certains
qu’il n’y a jamais eu de traversées à
destination de l’Amérique avant Christophe
Colomb. Il y a par exemple l’implantation
de scandinaves au Canada actuel aux alentours
de l’an 1000. Là y’a des preuves archéologiques,
le site s’appelle l’Anse aux Meadows,
sur l’île de Terre Neuve, un campement
viking tout ce qu’il y a de plus classique.
Ça a même été raconté en animé japonais.
Et puis, il ne faut pas oublier que traverser
l’Atlantique n’est pas le seul moyen d’atteindre
l’Amérique, y’a un autre océan de l’autre
côté. Alors, il est un peu plus grand, c’est
vrai… Mais rien d’infranchissable pour
les navigateurs exceptionnels que sont les
Polynésiens.
Aujourd’hui je vais vous parler d’une
traversée, prouvée archéologiquement je
le précise, entre la Polynésie et l’Amérique
du Sud. Mais la preuve n’est pas un site
d’habitat comme pour les vikings du Canada,
la preuve, c’est la patate douce.
Ipomoea batatas est une plante qui produit
des tubercules, exactement comme la pomme
de terre. Un tubercule, c’est un stock d’énergie
pour la plante qui lui permet de germer après
la mauvaise saison. Grâce à ses tubercules
comestibles, cette plante délivre de grandes
quantités d’énergie, qui peuvent être
stockées, en bref, c’est un aliment parfait.
Il se trouve que la patate douce est originaire
d’Amérique. La plus grande diversité génétique
de cette plante se rencontre en effet en Amérique
du Sud, du côté du Pérou et de l'Équateur,
ce qui constitue un très bon indice de son
origine. Or, il se trouve que la patate douce
était aussi présente partout en Océanie
avant l’arrivée des premiers navires européens.
Vous commencez à voir où je veux en venir.
Les études génétiques récentes, utilisant
des marqueurs moléculaires, ont montré que
les patates douces d’Océanie proviennent
de deux régions, Pérou/Equateur d’un côté
et Mexique/Caraïbes de l’autre. La deuxième
est liée à une diffusion récente, mais
la première, originaire du Pérou/Equateur,
correspond bien à une diffusion ancienne.
Grâce à des spécimens conservés dans des
jardins botaniques du monde entier, notamment
des clones de patate douce collectés par
James Cook en 1769, on peut aujourd’hui
connaître les premières étapes de sa diffusion.
Comme quoi, embarquer des naturalistes sur
les bateaux était plutôt une bonne idée.
C’est leur travail passionné et méticuleux,
qui permet aujourd’hui de résoudre cette
énigme. Pratiquement tous les spécimens
collectés en Polynésie au XVIIIe siècle
montrent une grande proximité génétique
avec les plantes sud-américaines. Un indice
très fort en faveur de contacts précolombiens.
Si la patate douce péruvienne, était présente
à Tahiti ou à Hawaï depuis des siècles,
c’est donc bien que des navigateurs polynésiens
ont dû la ramener d’Amérique. Mais attention
à ne pas sauter une étape, ce n’est pas
forcément le résultat d’une traversée
humaine. Il y a quand même plus de 6 000
kilomètres entre la Polynésie et le Pérou.
Peut-on imaginer que quelques spécimens de
patate douce aient dérivé tout seuls jusqu’en
Polynésie sur un fragment de radeau ? Après
tout, on sait que ça s’est déjà produit
dans d’autres cas.
On sait par exemple que les Hawaïens trouvaient
parfois sur leurs plages des morceaux de fer
provenant d’épaves japonaises. Quand James
Cook, encore lui, débarque en 1778, les Hawaïens
repèrent immédiatement les objets en fer
et lui demandent comment il les fabrique.
Cook est obligé de demander au forgeron du
navire de leur faire une démonstration.
Il n’est donc pas improbable que la patate
douce soit arrivée naturellement, au gré
des courants. Le chercheur Alvaro Montenegro,
dans une étude publiée dans le Journal of
Archaeological Science en 2008 a fait le point
sur cette hypothèse. Il montre, modélisation
informatique à l’appui, qu’une embarcation
laissée à dériver pendant deux ou trois
mois depuis la côte ouest de l’Amérique
du Sud a en effet pas mal de chances de venir
croiser Tahiti ou les Tuamotu.
On peut aussi penser que des graines transportées
dans les estomacs des oiseaux auraient pu
germer en Polynésie. Il y a très peu d’espèces
d’oiseaux susceptibles d’avoir fait ce
voyage depuis l’Amérique du Sud, mais bon,
là encore, pourquoi pas.
Sauf qu’il y a un élément qui vient dynamiter
la théorie de la diffusion naturelle de la
patate douce à travers l’océan, c’est
le vocabulaire. En effet, le mot employé
pour désigner la patate douce en quechua,
la langue du Pérou, est cumar. Sur la côte
de l’Equateur, chez les Kanyari, c’est
un mot pratiquement identique qui est utilisé,
cumal. Et il se trouve que partout dans l’océan
Pacifique, on utilise des noms très proches
:A Tahiti, c’est la forme ‘uumara qui
est attestée au XVIIIe siècle. Aux îles
Marquises, on nomme la plante umau-a. Dans
les îles Cook, trois termes sont attestés
: kuuara, ‘uuara et kuumara. A Hawaï, ce
sont les termes uala et uara qui sont attestés
au début du XIXe siècle. Sur l’île de
Pâques, c’est kumara, et en Nouvelle-Zélande,
c’est rekamaora, là on s’éloigne un
peu du mot d’origine, mais l’essentiel
de la sonorité est bien là.
En bref, vous l’avez compris, tous ces termes
dérivent d’une même racine, en même temps
c’est normal pour un tubercule... (# humour).
Pour expliquer qu’on utilise le même mot,
il faut nécessairement qu’il y ait eu contact
et échange d’informations entre des navigateurs
et des habitants de la côte. C’est pas
les oiseaux qui sont venus expliquer comment
ça s’appelait, ou alors des perroquets
éventuellement… (Des perroquets migrateurs,
amateurs de patate douce, qui font 6000 bornes
vers l’ouest, et qui te font un petit cours
de quechua en arrivant, sympa.)
En étudiant la variation de tous ces noms,
les linguistes parviennent aujourd’hui à
proposer une origine probable pour l’introduction
en Océanie. C’est sans doute en Polynésie
orientale sous la forme de kuumala que la
patate douce a été importée pour la première
fois depuis la côte de l’Amérique du Sud.
Elle a ensuite été diffusée au reste de
l’Océanie, avec ce nom sud-américain.
Les cartes montrent en réalité que la diffusion
épouse à la perfection la forme du triangle
polynésien classique, dont les pointes sont
la Nouvelle-Zélande au sud-ouest, Hawaï
au nord et l’île de Pâques à l’est,
et dont le centre est Tahiti. A l’exception
d’une partie ouest composée des Tonga et
des Samoa, restées en dehors de la diffusion
de la patate douce avant l’arrivée des
Européens.
C’est sans doute Cook, toujours lui, qui
introduit la patate douce aux Tonga lors de
son deuxième voyage en 1774. Là-bas, le
nom d’origine péruvienne n’est pas connu,
et les habitants nomment la plante « tani
», rien à voir avec kuumala. Plus à l’ouest,
les introductions aux Fidji, aux îles Salomon
et en Nouvelle-Calédonie ont dû avoir lieu
au XIXe siècle par le commerce et là encore,
le mot quechua est inconnu.
Grâce à la linguistique, on voit donc se
dessiner une route entre la Polynésie et
la côte de l’Equateur, qui aurait été
empruntée au moins une fois aller-retour.
Car en plus, cette région d’Amérique du
Sud est la seule où la navigation à voile
est attestée à l’époque précolombienne.
Les premiers Européens qui arrivent dans
la zone en 1526 découvrent des navires en
balsa pouvant transporter plus de 20 personnes
et plusieurs tonnes de marchandises. Il est
permis de penser que les habitants du golfe
de Guayaquil en Equateur ont emprunté cette
technologie aux Polynésiens puisque leurs
voiles triangulaires faisaient beaucoup penser
aux grandes pirogues d’Océanie.
Certains archéologues ont d’ailleurs proposé
que ce soient plutôt les sud-américains
qui aient été à l’origine de ces grandes
traversées. Le Norvégien Thor Heyerdahl
a sans doute été le plus loin pour appuyer
cette théorie. En 1947, cet archéologue
et aventurier a voulu démontrer la possibilité
d’un tel voyage depuis le Pérou. Il a ainsi
construit le Kon-Tiki, un bateau à voile
en rondins de balsa, assemblés avec des cordes.
Il est ensuite parvenu avec cinq hommes d’équipage
à rallier l’archipel des Tuamotu depuis
le côte péruvienne en 101 jours. Même si
elle ne prouve rien, l’odyssée du Kon-Tiki,
en montrant que c’était possible, a alimenté
cet intérêt pour les navigations précolombiennes
sur le Pacifique.
Heyerdal postulait, lui, un renversement complet
de l’origine du peuplement, faisant des
Polynésiens des descendants des Péruviens.
Mais la génétique et la linguistique sont
absolument claires là-dessus aujourd’hui,
le peuplement de la Polynésie s’est fait
par l’ouest, plusieurs millénaires avant
J.-C. et n’a rien à voir avec le Pérou.
Les Polynésiens maîtrisaient depuis longtemps
les technologies maritimes. Les voyages d’exploration
et des premiers peuplements ont vraisemblablement
été réalisés avec des pirogues à balancier,
parfaitement adaptées aux mers agitées et
conçues pour soutenir de grandes voiles.
Les pirogues à double coque, les ancêtres
des catamarans, ont ensuite permis de transporter
beaucoup de personnes et de chargement. Ce
seraient donc plus logiquement les Polynésiens
qui seraient allés visiter la côte américaine.
Ce sont eux qui possédaient le savoir-faire
en matière de navigation hauturière, probablement
pas les Péruviens.
Bon. Mais au-delà des indices linguistiques,
génétiques, et des échanges de techniques,
il y a quand même un élément qui nous manque.
Une preuve archéologique formelle. Une bonne
vieille patate douce ! Problème, les tubercules
se conservent très mal, comparées aux graines
par exemple. Heureusement pour nous, quelques
trouvailles de patates douces carbonisées
ont été faites et ont même pu être datées
au carbone 14. La première trouvaille a eu
lieu à Hawaï, et elle a été datée approximativement
du XVIIe siècle. C’est pas très ancien,
mais c’est quand même antérieur à l’arrivée
des Européens. Sur l’île de Pâques, de
nombreux éléments carbonisés attribués
à de la patate douce ont, eux, été datés
du XIIIe siècle.
Mais la découverte la plus importante provient
de Mangaia dans les îles Cook. (Il est partout)
Dans l’abri sous roche de Tangatatau, fouillé
en 1989, de nombreux restes de végétaux
carbonisés ont été mis au jour. Parmi eux,
plusieurs fragments de patates douces. Et
cette fois-ci les datations ne laissent aucun
doute sur l’ancienneté des contacts. Le
plus ancien fragment est daté de 980 BP à
plus ou moins 70 ans. Une fois calibrée,
ça tombe aux environs de l’an 1000 après
J.-C., à une époque où aucun navire européen
n’avait encore quitté l’Atlantique nord.
Ces trouvailles ont, par ailleurs, été faites
dans une stratigraphie parfaitement conservée
et associées à des artefacts comme des hameçons
et des haches, ce qui rend les datations très
solides.
La voilà la preuve. Des morceaux de patate
douce en stratigraphie avec des datations
cohérentes et corrélées à du matériel
archéologique. En ajoutant à cela que les
Polynésiens utilisent le mot d’origine
péruvienne, ça devient presque impossible
à réfuter.
Pour paraphraser Lévi-Strauss, on le voit,
la patate douce est bonne à manger, mais
elle est aussi « bonne à penser ». C’est
fou de se dire qu’une plante peut révéler
autant sur les contacts entre les sociétés
anciennes. Cette diffusion précolombienne
à travers l’océan Pacifique a intrigué
de nombreux chercheurs et motivé leur travail
pendant des années, tout comme elle nous
a intrigués et nous a donné envie de préparer
cette vidéo. D’autant que le premier qui
s’était sérieusement attelé à résoudre
cette énigme était Jacques Barrau dès les
années 1950. Barrau, on aime beaucoup son
travail ici, il était botaniste et anthropologue
et a beaucoup publié sur les relations entre
les humains et les plantes. Son travail est
toujours à la base de la plupart des études
d’ethno-botanique, d’ailleurs, allez-voir
si ça vous intéresse.
Depuis, bien sûr, de nombreux articles ont
été publiés sur le sujet, on en a montré
quelques-uns au cours de cette vidéo. Un
livre entier sur la question de la patate
douce préhistorique a même été écrit
en Australie par une vingtaine de chercheurs.
Comme on arrivait pas à mettre la main dessus
en France, on a écrit directement au directeur
de la publication, Chris Ballard de l’université
de Canberra. Il nous a immédiatement répondu
et nous a envoyé tous les chapitres du livre
en PDF, ça a beaucoup aidé la préparation,
alors merci infiniment à lui !
Encore une fois, c’est l’interdisciplinarité
qui permet de faire la lumière sur l’énigme
de la patate douce, en mêlant l’archéologie,
la botanique, l’océanographie, la génétique,
la linguistique, etc. Les réponses aux questions
ne sont peut-être pas encore d’une précision
totale étant donné l’aspect fragmentaire
des données disponibles, mais les grandes
lignes de ces contacts sont désormais bien
dessinées. Les Polynésiens sont allés en
Amérique il y a au moins mille ans et en
ont ramené la patate douce péruvienne, qu’ils
ont ensuite diffusée dans tout l’Océan
Pacifique.
A moins que ce soient des perroquets.
Merci à toutes à tous d’avoir regardé
cette vidéo, si vous avez envie de comprendre
en détail le travail insensé des archéologues
(qui parfois consiste à découvrir des fragments
de patate douce) allez découvrir Mission
Archéo, les premiers épisodes sont sortis
! C’est une série tournée lors de fouilles
archéologiques qui vous montre les découvertes
en direct, si vous aimez l’archéo cette
série vous plaira c’est certain !
Je vous remercie d’avoir regardé cet épisode,
je vous rappelle que vous avez une promotion
pour essayer durant 45 jours l’application
de lecture Nextory. De la lecture gratuite
pendant 45 jours en suivant ce lien qui s’affiche
ici et également juste sous la vidéo ! A
la prochaine, salut !